Saludos Rodrigo estoy ahora mismo en el
bulevar voltea pocos cientos de metros
de la Plaza de la república donde inicia
la manifestación de este Primero de Mayo
terminará en la Plaza de la nación y
pasará también por la casa por la Plaza
de la bastilla el ambiente de hoy se
manifiesta con diferentes expresiones
hemos hablado con muchísimos
manifestantes hay entusiasmo en ellos
una mezcla por supuesto de esa alegría
por la jornada que se celebra hoy pero
también de ira que se personifica en la
persona del presidente Emmanuel macron y
de la primera ministra Elizabeth Don
específicamente el rechazo a esa
promulgación reciente de la Reforma de
pensiones aquí en Francia que aumenta 64
años la edad de jubilación hay también
un sentimiento de excepcionalidad es la
primera gran movilización nacional
después de la promulgación de la ley es
el primero de mayo es la primera vez
desde 2009 en que todos los sindicatos a
la vez llaman a juntos y se ha
demostrado además que durante las doce
manifestaciones anteriores contra la
reforma de pensiones no se ha logrado
nada en concreto de forma que existe
también esa duda en si el movimiento Va
a continuar o no en este momento en toda
Francia hay trescientas acciones como
las de aquí de París qué se espera cerca
de un millón y medio de personas en las
calles según los sindicatos hay también
tensión aquí un gran número de efectivos
policiales doce mil desplegados esto es
inédito desde el inicio del movimiento
contra la reforma de pensiones espera
también la infiltración de movimientos
de elementos violentos que se llaman
aquí de riesgo entre cerca de 2000 entre
chalecos amarillos radicalizados
extremistas activistas de extrema
izquierda y los llamados Black vlogs
también de extrema izquierda de manera
que es una jornada de celebración de
exigencia de mejoras de las condiciones
de trabajo de protesta contra la reforma
de pensiones Y probablemente
depresiones violentas